[Music]  people talk about good old days  simpler times and better ways i guess  that i would have to say  it is just what it is  [Music]  time sure flies we're moving on  one day here the next day gone and then  sometimes you hear a song remember a  girl with long blonde hair  it makes you wanna be there  somehow it makes you wanna be there  right now  [Music]  a little town a high school team  we were somewhere in between  boys and men for what did sing a long  long time back then  an old ballpark  [Music]  [Applause]  that after 20 years we'd still see that  fastball in the air  it makes you wanna be there  right now  get in your car and go there  right now  out of the blue from nowhere  [Music]  it makes you wanna be there  right now  [Music]  flashback  down the track down the line way back in  time some memories never die  you just close your eyes  it makes you want to be there  right now  [Music]  [Music]  it makes you wanna be there  right now  [Music]  you